la troupe des déchiens inaugure par une
pièce intitulée le défilé le Festival
d'automne au théâtre de chillot à Paris
les Deschiens c'est un véritable
phénomène de société c'est rien de le
dire qui remet à la mode ce qui est
démodé c'est le triomphe disons
duringard sur le brancher ou le
contraireierry et did
d'ARM gilet à trourou au crochet façon
mémère sur Rob nilon rayon
[Musique]
quinciller c'est la revanche du
malfingué qui tout d'un coup a le droit
aux honneurs d'un podium la concierge
n'est plus dans l'escalier elle se prend
pour
[Musique]
claudiaif avec leurs imprimés su leur
costumes BJ ils sont aussi maladroits
que fier d'être là bref c'est un peu
nous d'où leur énorme
succès maintenant c'est quasi
sociologique
[Musique]
il y a quelque chose dans la façon de
traduire le malaise des gens leé à vivre
quotidien par
exoness T le Frot réalité
quotidienne le vêtement ça parleidentité
de tout difficulté à avoir une
[Musique]
identité les mod
auun
[Musique]
cliché comme de vrais min ils ont le
regard inaccessible et profond qui at le
respect des
branchesérô des champ son chien et ses
Deschiens ont accéléré et bouleversé le
retour au années 70 des grands
couturiers pas de doute le vent des
chiens souffle sur la France des
magasins ont vite pris crneau comme k
dernier endroit à la mode c'est Maron
orang à fleur ou cacadois et ça plat des
gens qui demandent quelque chose façon
des chiens carrément ou il y a des gens
qui demand bien s y gens qui on le des
chi touteçon à la be et les modes pass
si vite que s'amuser à être ringard
volontaire disciple des des chiens c'est
peut-être un bon rempart pour ne rien
rater